déjà en premier je n'arrive pas à le
croire merci papa il faut qu'on parle de
ta santé sexuelle
je t'en supplie ne veux pas que tu
prennes de risques a pas pourquoi tu me
donnes des préservatifs surtout amuse
toi bien ouais je crois que là j'ai tout
ce qu'il faut pour ça justement
merci je crois que tu devrais voir ça
comme une occasion d'élargir concernant
on sait jamais ce qui peut se passer
c'est justement ce qui me fait peur
mes lettres sont mes trésors les plus
secrètes j'ai créé une lettre chaque
fois que j'ai un coup de coeur si
intense que je sais pas quoi faire
d'autre
j'en ai écrit pour cinq garçons peter et
ses beaux yeux
kenny du camp de vacances le cas du bal
de l'école john du club de modélisation
de l'onu et hitch le petit copain de ma
soeur on peut savoir ce que tu fais ou
rien du tout personne ne connaît leur
existence est ce que je peux te parler
ouais ça me touche mais ça n'arrivera
jamais je te demande pardon je trouve ça
super cool qu'il pense que j'ai des
petites taches tort les lettres ont été
envoyées les femmes
je te le fais pas dire il faut que je
t'explique
je suis pas réellement amoureuse de toi
je devais seulement donné l'impression
de l'être
mais si on laissait les autres croire
qu'on était réellement ensemble juste
pendant quelque temps chez par teinte
[Musique]
si tu avais jamais vu aussi heureuse
tu pensais ce que tu as dit dans la
lettre que je mentais à tout le monde
autour de moi
le cache pas cette partie de toi
l'accord gêné
tu peux pas rester caché dans sa chambre
à écrire des lettres d'amour que tu en
verras jamais
clara jean tu dois dire aux gens ce que
tu ressens au moment où tu le ressens tu
m'as pas vu